over the weekend, as you know, I a was totally
fist connected from news and politics, but
some friends of mine, we're talking
about Trump and politics and I was sort of
just listening, uh, and I started thinking
that I would really respect the American right
and the Trumpist right.
Way More if they stop making excuses for Donald
Trump.
And specifically I'm talking about the racism
and xenophobia and the incompetence.
And if they just said, you know what?
Yeah, it's true.
He is all of those things.
But here's why I still support him.
Because what I really am trying to get to
here is that the pro Trump right has kind
of twisted itself into pretzels with these
completely incredible defenses of the things
that Donald Trump has said and things that
Donald Trump has done.
And when it was simply bad policy, it was
a little bit easier to hide the total impossibility
of their defenses.
So I'll give you an example.
When Donald Trump passed tax reform, uh, well
with Republicans and rich people said, we
like this because it's going to be great for
the economy.
That's wrong, right?
Like that's demonstrably wrong, but it's at
least true that there are people who think
tax cuts for the rich are good for the economy.
So what they mean is these tax cuts are good
for me, right?
But they hide it as these tax cuts are good
for the country, even though that's obviously
not the case.
Okay.
When Donald Trump, alien, alien, aids another
European ally, that's bad for us.
But Trump is, can argue I don't care because
we've been taken advantage of by the European
Union for too long.
I like that we finally have a president that's
going to hold them to account.
Now, I would disagree with that and lots of
them are simply hiding behind the reality
that they're simply ultranationalists anti
Europeans, but at least they have some policy
explanation for why they can pretend that
Donald Trump is doing something that makes
sense.
But now with the last 10 days, on top of the
last two years obviously, but the very acute
last 10 days of the xenophobic and racist
stuff that Trump has been ramping up with,
the defenses are not even slightly believable.
Trump's whole send her back thing wasn't racist
because it was the crowd chanting, not Donald
Trump himself.
The entire attack on four ethnic minority
Congress women wasn't race sisters in a phobic
because Trump simply wants our country to
be good and he's criticizing anyone who said
or did what they've done a because he thinks
that it's the wrong direction for the, that's
all that it is.
It's not racist.
It's an as you know, phobic.
These aren't believable defenses and these
aren't respectable defenses.
And I am saying, I'm sorry, I'm actually speaking
to the Trump is straight.
Now, very often on the show I say, I know
that there were Trumpists listening, but I'm
not speaking to them.
They're, they're off the deep end.
I'm speaking to the reasonable people in our
audience.
This is different.
Okay?
I'm actually speaking to the Trump is tier.
I would respect you way more if you just told
the truth.
Okay.
And for some of you, the truth is you're also
raised as racist and xenophobic, and that's
why you like Donald Trump's a dog.
Whistles.
Just come out and say it.
Okay.
Stop pretending.
Stop couching it all as merely political rhetoric
or strategy or a healthy version of [inaudible]
nationalism or whatever.
Just tell me, I think these things about minorities
and I believe Donald Trump agrees with me
and I like it and that's why I like him.
I would vehemently disagree with you.
I would vehemently disagree with what I believe
is a disgusting and self-destructive view
of human relations on our planet, but I would
respect you for just telling it like it is
or for other people.
They don't actually like the racist and xenophobic
stuff, but they're playing along because they've
calculated the Donald Trump is good for them
in some other way.
Personally, like if you're a rich person who
just got this massive, massive tax cut last
year because of Donald Trump, just tell me,
you know what?
I am disgusted by what Donald Trump is saying.
It is racist.
It is in a phobic, but I'm going to ignore
it because the tax cut is just so good for
me.
Or the trade stuff happens to be good for
my personal financial interests or whatever.
I'd think you were greedy at the expense of
what's best for your country, but I would
respect you because you're just telling me
the truth.
When Trump talks about caging children and
criminal illegals and Mike Pence turns his
back literally uncaged immigrants don't play
the, I like this because I'm for strong borders,
but I want legal immigrants here.
Don't play the IC people as equal stuff.
Just come out and tell me.
I like what Trump is doing with immigrants
because I agree with him about we don't want
people from asshole whole countries here.
I agree with Tucker Carlson that immigrants
are making our country dirtier.
Just tell me you don't like the Brown people
or at least you don't think they're good for
our country.
I would respect you way more than when you
pretend that there are concrete and sensible
policy reasons to support this garbage and
I have breaking news for you.
Increasingly, you don't even really have to
hide that.
That's the case.
I know there may be people in the audience
who say, you know, David's kind of right.
I do just not want Brown people here or I
do turn them on the other cheek because a,
a the, this actually is aligned with my nationalist
beliefs or whatever else Trump's running on
this type of bigotry now.
So just come out of the closet.
Okay, stop pretending.
Just admit why it is that you love it and
we go from there and maybe we can have some
real conversations about why you hold these
views instead of continuing to tell all of
these completely absurd stories that quite
frankly, no one with any common sense should
be falling for in terms of why you support
or defend the actions of Donald Trump because
there are no actual conservative values that
are being defended with this nonsense.
You're either propping up your personal greed
and to sort of what's best for me point of
view or you're propping up your own xenophobia
and racism.
I just want to hear you tell it like it is
when you call into my show as Trump is, do
don't play the Games of, you know, Trump really
didn't have a role in the center back thing.
He did try to stop it right away, which is
a lie, which we'll deal with later today.
Just say, I like it.
I do want to send them back.
Those are my politics.
And then we can actually talk like real adults
once we established what our positions are,
get away from these ridiculous, unbelievable
talking points.